- 'Cause unlike that
University diploma that you're
going to end up buying,
paying full retail for,
is going to get you your gig necessarily.
We're taught in the system
that failure is something
that you should be ashamed of.
Failure is for the dumb kids.
The minute you feel like
you've arrived is the
minute ya know, you soften up.
- Hello Believe Nation,
I'm Evan Carmichael.
My One Word is Believe and
I believe that entrepreneurs
are going to solve all of the
major problems of the world.
So to help you on your journey,
today we're going to learn
from fashion designer
Mark Ecko and my take
on his top ten rules for success.
Rule number one is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which
one you guys like the best.
And as always guys, as
you're watching, if you hear
something that really resonates with you,
please leave it down
in the comments below.
Put quotes around it so
other people can be inspired
and when you write it
down, it's much more likely
to stick for yourself as well, enjoy.
(swooshing)
(ball bouncing)
(upbeat music)
- How many you guys, hands, show of hands,
how many of you folks here have a goal?
Alright, you sure, you
sure you have a goal>
Keep your hands up, hands stay up.
Are you sure you have a goal?
Now keep your hands up
if you could believe
you could realize that goal no matter what
twists and turns come in your life?
Any little trepidation, I
see some hands comin' down.
For those that have kept their hands up,
you are all entrepreneurs, alright?
Give yourself a hand, 'cause
that's what it's going to take.
(applause)
And don't be like entrepreneur,
get your mouth around
that word entrepreneur,
what does that mean?
Don't be a regular entrepreneur.
Be a beast, okay, get it done.
Just know, you got to
like the opportunity now
to kind of be industrious
and what's gating us.
There are no limitations as
to what's gating us, right?
There's so many efficiencies
built into media,
technology and broadcasting,
publishing, portraying
yourself, visualizing
yourself as a brand, yourself,
independently, right, that
shame on you for not trying
and making something out of it, like
that's the window we live in right now.
It's not like the schools are
going to figure it out, right?
'Cause unlike that University
diploma that you're
going to end up buying,
paying full retail for
is going to get you your
gig necessarily, right.
So the window to kind of
like capture the hustle
and to do something with it on your terms,
it is a really exciting time right now.
Needless to say, in '93,
I dropped out of college.
I started my business and
it occurred to me that
I was going to be very
average at pharmacology
and I was going to be something
above average when I was
working on what I loved which
was painting and creating.
And that finding that
pearl, that passion point
to build your business around,
there's, it's so cliche,
people talk about passion but
with all the ups and downs
of running a business
and creating a business
and the uncertainties of
markets and you arrive
at the gates of success
and I remember thinkin'
I'll be rich young, when
you arrive at a place where
you would think that
that would suffice, like
a true entrepreneur, someone
who is, someone who wants
to discover what's next,
someone who has to be working
on what they love will not
be satiated or satisfied
with just the money, it's not enough.
It's the learning that comes
through doing what you love.
And for me, that's been the blessing
and the good fortune of what I've had.
I think the best advice that
I could give you on success
is to know that success if
merely the hangover of failure.
And that failure is an
essential ingredient in
creating a learning
atmosphere for you so that
you can accrue those
learnings, those small
incremental steps of
failure and collect enough
learning so that you can
arrive at success, right.
I think we're taught in
the system that failure is
something that you should be ashamed of.
Failure is for the dumb
kids 'cause you get an F.
You get a D, right, you're not competent.
You didn't comply, you
didn't create the evidence
of your worthiness and I
could tell you as someone
who's successful, right,
both financially and from
a wealth creation point of
view but more importantly, a
wealth that matter that success
doesn't look like an A plus.
It doesn't look like 110 in extra credit
and failure isn't as simple as an F.
And it's not always, like
failure could be very gray
and being able to discern
what you might arrive at
an event or in your life
where you think that wow,
I've succeeded and you're
getting the affirmation
from all these outside
forces but if it's not
aligned authentically with
to whom which you are,
it could very much feel like failure.
You're going to fail, it's okay, okay?
You're going to fail, and I'm
not talkin' about the tests.
That's one thing, I'm
talkin' about to your knees,
your skin, bloody, fail and that's okay
'cause you know what,
you know down deep inside
of all of you that's how you learn.
You need to be motivated by failure.
How'd you learn how to walk?
You crawled, then you fell
down, busted your tooth,
got some blood in your mouth, get up
and you walk, right, self directed.
- [Interviewer] I always wondered
why it was a rhino as a logo.
- Why the rhino, it's
one of those manna from
the heaven things, three
years into the business
I was at a trade show
and all my competitors
had kind of the same
logo, everyone was using
like a graffiti word
mark and I just felt like
how am I going to differentiate
myself from the rest of
the pack and I went back to my
home in Lakewood, New Jersey
where I grew up and that
was the spot I used to
airbrush t shirts out of
my garage and right off
of the room where I would
air brush, my dad had
a collection of little
wood sand drift rhinos.
They're probably like two
dollars a piece or whatever.
And I just started a riff
on it and I brought it to
the market one piece at a
time and I remember the buyers
were like, we don't know
about that dinosaur.
(laughing)
We don't know about that hippopotamus
and they were like give
me more graffiti t shirts.
I'm like alright but I
want to establish a logo
like Polo or Nike or Timberland.
And they weren't really
tryin' to feel that.
And just staying persistent
and it kind of started to stick
so one t shirt became three became five
became ya know, the logo
but like logos are like
guns without ammo so it was
really what we did with it
I think, that made it more meaningful.
Sometimes when it's all
about you, like I said,
like never get high on
your own supply, right.
When it's all about you, you know or like
Biggie says actually,
right, or actually Scarface
if we go back all the way
to the original reference
but you know that, you
can't think that like
you're the only game in town.
That's a really dangerous
thought process, man.
Collaboration is good and
it's healthy and working
with young cats that are
coming up and they have
their own revenge fantasies,
we cold learn from that.
I'm not too old to learn,
man, I've been going to
school since, I might now
have been in the classroom
but school's come to me,
like when you want to
learn, school comes to you.
So I am content being a student.
- Well, you've had a lot
a success with Complex
in a very short period of
time, when did you start it?
- Well, it's not really that short.
That's what's interesting,
it's like 15, almost 15 years.
- So it took you 15 years to
become an overnight success.
- In 2000.
- There is no such
thing as an overnight success.
- Yeah, it's one of the great falisies.
- I say this all the time, it's the
biggest American lie
told, overnight success.
- Yeah, it's a falisy man,
I'm always auditioning.
Always on some new, like it's always new.
It's and the minute you feel like you've
arrived is the minute you soften up
and you can't, listen,
I've had enough experiences
in my career, ups, downs, sideways, right,
stay on that track and I
think that's where I'm at
now in my profession, I
think both of us are like,
we're just like let's just go get it.
- Full steam ahead.
- The first decade of my
career, I think I got more
value out of that, that
kind of affirmation of
being above average with my
hands and with my creativity
than ya know, than the
actual cash I collected.
I reflect back on it, I probably.
- [Interviewer] That's not
corny to feel that way.
- Well, no, I made good
money but it's funny,
even at 41 today, there's
that line that's this mania,
it's like a line of madness that is just,
it sits you in a way that
just the transactional
side of collecting stuff,
right, filling your
house up with more stuff, more, ya know.
It fills you in a way that
just pursuing the money can't.
When you create wealth,
there's like, you could
just create wealth or you could
create wealth that matters.
And I made a distinction
in my life that that's very
important to me and when
I take an inventory of
the things that I've
done, they all, I can't
necessarily measure them in
finite numbers of success,
of like dollars, right, like you can't.
Some of the most impactful
things you can't necessarily
measure with a dollar amount,
it's more qualitative, right.
It's more like it's in
your stomach, right.
It's like a feeling
thing and there, there's
certainly things that I've
done that I'm really proud of
that probably excite me more
than any material stuff.
For me, inspiration is a
journey, it is not a destination.
Okay, it is a self motivated
internally motivated process.
It's not this glamorous
thing, it is mundane.
It is not something that
just because you arrive at
the gates of success, that
somehow as a new experience,
it's different than when
you were not successful.
It is exactly the same, I find
inspiration on blank pages.
I find inspiration in my habits, okay,
in moments of quiet, the
intimacy on a heavy bag
alone, sweating, if
it's me and a kettlebell
or me taking a walk and
just breathing in, okay,
literally breathing in, I'm
able to harvest inspiration.
I created a formula that
I want to share with you.
I'm not much for math but this is
the idea of a unique voice.
When you transform,
when you shed your skin,
the important thing to
hold onto is your voice.
What have I done, what am
I the most proud of in life
besides my kids, I'm the
most proud of realizing
and listening to, despite
all the voices, my own voice
and trying to craft the unique voice.
I say that it's what you
do, it's action minus fear,
okay, divided by yourself, how
selfish or selfless are you?
This is the idea of unique voice.
Try to break it down for you very simply.
If you're fearful, we
know being fearful sucks.
I mean, it immobilizing
you, it arrests you from
expressing yourself,
right, now being completely
fearless, you could be reckless.
But fear with purpose, right,
to yourself to your voice
is meaningful and that's when
real unique voices emerge.
And it's not much, it's not
enough to just talk, right?
Like someone like Ali,
he didn't just talk.
Let me tell you somethin',
doing and talking,
two different things, action
is the great equalizer, okay?
We live at a time there's so much noise,
so much chatter in the
system, people just.
(inaudibly rambling)
A lot of people really fearless ideas
but they don't act on it,
right, that's the dilemma.
And when you act on it,
you become a unique voice.
Those are the voices
they make monuments to.
Self, well you could
either be really selfless
like Gandhi who's like
one in a gazillion, right.
Like completely selfless or really selfish
that even when you got
everybody tellin' you
everything that you
want to hear, you still
won't listen to anyone but yourself.
That's the worst type to be
but there's some balance of
self, there is a degree
of selfishness that you
have to kina get to to filter the noise
and establish your unique voice.
So this is the unique voices
of a generation, right?
This is how unique
voices emerge young boys
that sell more records than Elvis, right?
People that change the
world, that's what unique
voices are about, man,
saying like Kanya and Abe
both two great guys from Illinois, right.
So I challenge all of you,
each and every one of you
from the inside out, guts
to the skin to the tape
to the denture glue, right, figure
out your unique voice, nurture it.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Ephect asked me to.
So if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you
would like me to cover
next, check with the
link in the description
and go and cast your vote.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Kelly Quittenton
from youandkellyq.com,
Kelly, thank you so much
for picking up a 10 copies of my book
and giving it to your friends.
I really appreciate the support
and I'm glad that you enjoyed the read.
So thank you guys again for watching,
I believe in you, I hope you continue
to believe in yourself and
whatever your own word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
(whooshing)
(basketball bouncing)
- I am a brand, I say
you are a brand if you
like it or not, if you know it or not.
Now some people get
uncomfortable with that.
Like if you two guys
if Envy and Charlamagne
are like Angela and Envy,
if you guys went to lunches.
Let's talk about our personal brands.
You probably would vomit
on each other, right,
'cause it's so like a sappy, goopy.
- It seems self serving.
- It's seems so like
patronizing to think about it
but there is a best practice
of being honest and saying,
alright well let me take
an honest inventory, guts
to the skin of what I'm
composed of and does
everything that I'm working on
reflect that because that
is your personal brand.
We build like an
entrepreneurial eco system there
that's really empowered a
lot of independent thought
leaders either in video
production or in blogging
or in fashion and in independent music
and for me, looking at
that pipe, the pipe that
serves a lot of this
content and it's kind of
pursuit of excellence
'cause it's very easy to
go the cheap route on it and we didn't.
We took the hard route, I think
that's one of the great achievements.
Somehow we think this
notion of artist or creator
culturally is an indulgent notion.
It's what self indulgent,
self philosophical people
that get to dress in
all black and lean back
and get to be moody and
self loathing, right,
this is, that we're sloppy,
right, that we don't
necessarily have the, we're right brained.
Right brain, artist,
right brain, don't give
him the spreadsheet or it's
just not for you, right,
because as you get older,
maybe you lose perhaps some
of that swagger or that
freedom that when you were
in second grade where you
just would raise your hand
and say yes I am in fact an artist.
We also think that this
notion of creator and artist
is divine, right, there's
some divine thing.
The famous Michelangelo
image and then we struggle
in commercializing it so we
think that there's a holy
war between creative and art and commerce
and this inhibits our ability
and our relationship with our art, right,
so I challenge folks who
perhaps don't necessarily
fancy themselves artists
that just because you
can't manipulate paint or
sculpt or music doesn't
mean that you shouldn't
problem solve like an artist,
that you have to learn to embrace
the messiness of creation,
embrace the mess, problem
solve like an artist.
Give yourself more than one percent.
(swooshing)